Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April fucking seventh.
What's going on?
How are you,
I apologize for the,
uh,
the bad sound on the recording.
Um,
I am right now,
I am overseas.
I am in Gay Patty.
I don't mean that in a homophobic way.
Um,
I was just what they call it.
I think gay still means happy over here.
It used to mean happy and,
uh,
United States of America before gay people stole that word,
you know?
And then started telling people how they can use it,
how they can't use it.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
You don't know the word
anyways.
Um,
I mean,
how come stupid,
you know,
how come dope and stupid could actually meet something good?
Right?
What'd you gay can't meet?
That's leg,
I guess because it's,
it's,
it's coming from gay meeting,
uh,
same sex.
I don't know.
I've never understood it.
I could say like,
you know,
that that fucking band is dig gay meaning lane and still not care if gay people
get married.
Why?
Why does everybody have to be a fucking parent right now?
And just say what you can say and what you can't say.
It doesn't make a difference.
What the fuck you say?
It's what's in your fucking
right.
All you're doing is you're just given a roadmap for psychos on how to get
through the minefield without showing the hand,
you know,
and that's how you end up with another Hitler.
I'm joking.
Maybe a mousseline you though.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna try not to move the car
jewelry had,
the reason why I'm recording this way is because,
uh,
I finally figured it out after two times being over here or overseas.
I think I was in Australia one time and I've blown out my fucking mixer,
mixer.
Uh,
what I figured out over here for you,
you people,
my countrymen in the states,
uh,
do not plug anything with two only two prongs into a fucking wall over here.
My experiences it,
it either blows out the plug that's the best case scenario or just completely
damages and fucks over whatever device you were trying to put in.
I've lost two mixers.
I tried to plug my iPhone in and I'm saying this is with an adapter to um,
I didn't just stick it on a wall.
I actually used an adapter and uh,
I did that with my,
uh,
my iPhone charger for the four s and think fucking blew up.
I should have known because I was charging it earlier and it was working fine
and when I pulled it onto the wall was really hot.
Now I don't understand electricity.
To me it's still magic and you somehow trapped lightening and put it in the
wall.
That's what electricity is to me.
It's lightning,
you know,
cause my only education about it was when all fat.
So with his male pattern baldness in his fucking,
that glasses flew the kite down there in Philly,
you know,
any went out there and he was all hammered because a,
he was making excuses for his alcoholism.
Isn't that what he did?
He said yeah,
beer is proof that God loves us.
Yeah.
What else fills the old man?
He must have been coming down the street with his giant Mug.
I Bet Ben Franklin was the first one to have like a personalized mug at a bar or
something like the first norm from cheers as he comes stumbling in this stupid
swearing.
Witticisms witticisms witticisms however the fuck you say it.
I Dunno.
Um,
anyways,
so yeah,
I'm over here on vacation.
Finally took a vacation.
I've always wanted to come here and why the fuck not right?
What else am I going to do?
Huh?
Go to fucking Santa Fe.
Uh,
no,
I've always wanted to come here and it has been absolutely incredible and I did
not brush up on my French whatsoever.
I mean,
there wasn't really anything to brush up on.
I like how I just said that as if I was at one point semi fluent in the
language.
I wasn't,
I will tell you that I took it from sixth grade to 12th grade and I never
progressed past French one.
And I'm actually,
I did,
I got the French two way and I did so poorly.
My Dad suggested,
why don't you go back to French one and start over again and get the basics?
And I was like,
all right,
that sounds like a good idea.
And in theory it was a good idea cause I still had my junior and senior years to
get through French two and have my two years of a language,
you know,
because that was a big thing when I went to,
when I went to high school,
you have to have two years of language.
If you don't have two years of a language,
you're not going to be able to get into any college worth anything.
In the United States of America of course,
turned out to be complete horse shit.
All you have to do with you fuck up in high school is go to any college that you
want to go to and just say,
listen,
can I just start taking courses to prove that I can exist if this academic
level?
And then the head is,
they just think,
yeah,
we'll take your money.
Stupid.
We'll take it.
Go ahead.
Thanks for a couple of classes.
Flunk out and we got your money.
You dumb fuck.
But if you actually hang in there,
eventually they have to accept you.
That's the other way to get into a big school.
You know,
me personally,
I think what you should really do,
if you want to say some fucking money and you weren't born daddy Warbucks I
don't even know if that's the right reference.
I've never seen.
And I thought the whole thing was offensive.
I didn't like how Andy looked exactly how I looked when I was a child in the 70s
and that they then made it a woman.
I took it as a personal attack.
But that's a whole other fucking story.
Um,
anyways,
if you weren't born into a rich family,
what you really want to do is go to a,
go to a community college for your first two years.
What's that like?
700 bucks a year or semester or whatever the fuck it is.
You're not that out.
This half you fucking college education,
bing,
Bang,
boom.
You haven't been,
you haven't had to pay shit.
And then you get,
and then you transfer to a bigger school in the better school and then you only
have to pay two years.
And you know what the end of it,
you've got the same degree hanging on the fucking walls,
the other jerk off.
Um,
but anyways,
anyways,
back to being hammered France.
Uh,
so what I've been doing is I've been going onto this duo lingo
website and I gotta tell you it's been phenomenal and I've been over here in
Paris having conversations,
you know,
basic conversations in French with these Parisian who I told were unbelievably
rude and to just speak English to them cause they hate when you try and speak
French and they'll roll their eyes and you'll try to talk to them in English and
they'll leave a stomp away or they'll just speak to you in English,
condescending,
all of that shit.
I have to tell you my experience,
um,
nothing could be further from the truth.
These people have been ridiculously polite,
that really fucking Nice.
And if you're making an effort to speak their language,
they're actually cool with it.
If you just sit there and you're like,
uh,
blah,
whatever we go,
do I say that right?
And they'll laugh and they'll just kind of help you along with it.
That's what I find.
I found a couple of impatient people,
but you know what the fuck?
Um,
I dunno.
I think it Kinda goes back to that,
that same thing like with New Yorkers,
I always heard New Yorkers are rude and pushy and when I moved there I didn't
find that I found it to be really friendly.
So,
uh,
either
people are making up shit or I'm fucked up.
One of the other,
it's probably a little bit of both,
but I've been here for about five days and uh,
I can't say enough about the people,
man.
I,
I think they're great.
And um,
the lovely me,
she's unbelievable when it comes to speaking other languages.
She just like,
yeah,
I swear to God,
I was telling her the other day like she could be like a spy because she'll sit
there and she'll start speaking in French and a French is so good that they just
roll with it here and then they start saying
shit and I know via doesn't know what they're talking about,
but she doesn't betray that on a space.
She just sits in the pocket and she watches the body language and their
mannerisms and she picks up on what they're saying.
And then she responds to it with the French that she knows or if she doesn't,
she gives him a smile and then asks them in English is that we are talking about
and they absolutely fucking lover me.
On the other hand,
I've been able to get to,
uh,
I had one cab ride that was entirely in French.
MMM.
Which like made my whole fucking trip.
I figured this is how you learn the language.
If you ever lived over here,
uh,
how to get,
you know,
have a cab ride in ordering food seems to be the way to go the first time.
So I can find to learn all these different,
you know,
words for food in that type of shit over here.
But it's been,
uh,
it's been tremendous.
I've always wanted to come here and I got to tell you,
um,
the limited amount of places that I've been to over here or around the world,
I should say,
ah,
this is
visually the most unbelievable city I've ever been to.
I mean,
uh,
the sons of bitches knew what they were doing when they were laying this thing
out.
It's incredible.
Absolutely incredible.
Like I've been to like,
I think three parks here
are two,
two giant parts here that could fuck with central park.
Well,
and then as big as central park,
they have another one that's as big as central park.
I haven't been to that one yet.
You know,
it's funny,
as I looked it up on the internet and I guess at night that's where the hookers
are.
And you know what I gotta tell you they'll,
hookers are pretty fucking gorgeous.
That's another thing too.
Best liquid fucking women.
As far as a country I've ever gone to.
And that includes,
I mean,
this just might be personal tastes as includes Sweden and Norway,
where the women would drop dead gorgeous.
And uh,
Iceland to like the French women at fucking unbelievable plus that speak in
French.
You know,
who the hell doesn't like a gorgeous woman speaking French?
I don't,
maybe you don't,
this is just on my own personal opinions here,
but um,
anyways,
these other two parks at that I've gone to,
um,
the way that they do it,
it's like you walk into the park and it's sort of,
you're covered like this trees all around you and that's beautiful enough with
park benches and all that.
MMM.
And then you basically,
I don't know how far,
I don't know how many meters so many yet,
but you get all the way in,
um,
whatever about four or five football fields in.
Once you get in,
all of a sudden it just comes to this like giant open area and then you have
these 365 degree views of like museums,
old governmental buildings,
or like the Eiffel Tower all of a sudden will just be there like a,
like a god Damn Mountain in the distance.
It's,
um,
literally breathtaking,
you know,
and I know you guys are going to trash me for saying that,
but I,
I swear to God it's a,
it's,
I can't say enough about it and,
um,
if I was ever going to live,
I think somewhere else,
I mean,
first of all,
I always wanted to learn to speak another language and also this displaces
incredible and I've only seen a little bit of it and I'll tell you about it,
uh,
after,
after these messages here,
I got to do a little bit of advertising here.
I apologize for the click and sound if this is like extra loud,
but like I said,
my fucking mix,
it only has a,
he has the two prongs and I'm not sticking that in the wall because you know I
buy like $90 mixer.
So that's another thing too about your devices over here.
If you've got something that costs you about a hundred bucks and some sort of
elect piece of electronics,
do not plug it into the fucking wolf with or without an adept,
but without an adapter,
it's probably gonna blow up,
um,
as opposed to just getting shorted out the other way.
Okay,
here we go.
I'm stamp stop,
calm everybody.
Um,
the post office is always crowded.
Now it will be even more crowded with people mailing in their taxes,
but you still need to get out of envelopes and packages for your business.
What do you do?
Use stamps.com instead stamps.com brings all the services for the post office
right to your desk.
It's so convenient and easy to use.
You can buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package using your computer and printer,
then just handed to your mailman stamps.com even send you a free digital scale
that automatically calculates the extra post as unique.
And the scale is scale is yours to keep.
You'll never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs,
my posters,
uh,
my,
my real life bill burr buttons,
whatever the thing I'm selling,
you know,
whatever I'm whoring out at the end of my shows.
Uh,
right now you can use my last name bur bur for this special offer,
a no risk trial plus a free $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and
up to $55 in free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are our that stamps.com enter burp.
Um,
next,
what do we got here?
Oh,
legal zoom.
Everyone.
Modern technology is great.
Smartphones,
iPads and other gadgets make it easy to do so many things,
but why is it that our lives seem busier at the same time?
Well,
I got theories on that but I don't have time to totally tell you about them.
Ah,
well when it comes to get into the legal help you need,
legal zoom provides a great solution that works with your busy schedule.
Let's face it,
the legal system is complicated.
Um,
there are better things you could do with your time.
Thankfully legal zoom is there for you.
So if you're thinking about starting a business,
forming an LLC or getting a trademark will or living trust,
legal zoom gets the job done right,
you'll get the personal attention you need that help you take care of all the
details,
legal zones,
but helping families and small business owners for over 14 years and they
received an a plus from the better business bureau and a plus.
People call or visit Legal Zoom today for an ESP extra discount.
Enter Burt in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com discount code birth legal zoom provides legal help through
independent attorneys and self help services.
But it is not a law firm.
Go to legalzoom.com enter discount code burr.
Okay.
Um,
and what do we got here?
One More Dollar Shave Club.
Everyone.
Nothing feels better than that first shave with a fresh blade,
right?
It's smooth,
it's close in.
The blade is as sharp as ever.
Um,
it feels fantastic,
but thanks to the big shapes what?
But thanks to the big shapes companies,
ridiculous prices.
You can't afford,
use a fresh blade every week.
Kenya.
So you drag that Dell last blade across your Frakes phase for two weeks,
three weeks,
10 weeks,
however long,
depending on your cash situation.
Why would you do that to yourself?
Maybe because the only thing more painful than shaving with an old blade is
shelling out 30 bucks for a pack of new ones.
Um,
if you want to enjoy a fresh blade every week,
but you don't want to take out another mortgage on your house,
you got to join dollar shape.com for just a couple of bucks,
bucks a month,
dollar shave club.com ships the highest quality blade you can get.
Um,
I use these things when I'm out here on the road.
They're absolutely phenomenal.
Everything that's saying about them is true.
And you know what?
It's only six bucks for the best quality blades you can get.
So every week I can pop in a fresh blade and treat myself to an amazing shave.
I try it.
I'm finally treating my face like my own face.
You know,
it's incredible.
Uh,
join dollar shave club.com.
Get amazing quality Bray blades in the mail,
every couple for a couple of bucks and treat yourself to a brand new blade every
single week.
Hundreds of thousands of guys have upgraded their shaving with dollar shave
club.com.
I'm one of them and I'm loving it.
Now it's your turn.
Shave time,
shave money,
dollar shave club.com/birth.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar.
All right.
Back to the podcast here.
Um,
oh and I also forgot to mention,
uh,
I did have a couple of things that I wanted to bring up before I get going too
far.
Uh,
the all in comedy tour checked off at,
um,
Jesus Christ.
Not where the fuck is it?
Is it right here?
Yeah,
there we go.
To the
all things comedy tour kicked off down at Largo last Monday.
Hosted by yours.
Truly.
All right.
Chicken,
uh,
chicken.
All my buddies out of the nest here so they can go out on the road and a
headline themselves.
Headline their own towards the all in comedy tours starring,
uh,
Roosevelt tailgate legends,
Joe Barton,
Nick,
Jason,
law head.
And uh,
my good friend Paul Versey.
Um,
I actually got some great feedback on the tour.
They did their first date alone down in San Diego.
And here's a review because an email like got a dear William,
I might be your biggest west coast fan.
I saw you on New Year's eve and just checked out the all in show in San Diego
last week.
Wow.
Those guys were hilarious.
Joe,
Jason and Andrew,
Andrew Feminist,
who helps me on the podcast here,
actually came down for the show,
uh,
would just as awesome as they worked.
The Wiltern Joe Bart.
Nick is an animal.
There's never been a truer thinks that he says,
if that's the way he does comedy,
I hate to see him drunk.
Actually.
You'd love to see him drunk.
A lawyer.
There's a spitfire.
He did a great person,
nation of the guy from bar rescue by request of the other guys on the show.
Oh,
by the way,
we got a video of that.
We've got,
have some video of that.
Uh,
Jason Law had,
does a fucking hilarious impression of the bar rescue guy.
We're going to have that up here on the podcast page.
Um,
and he said,
I was quoting Andrew Feminists to my coworkers the next day and now on Diversey.
Holy Shit.
Paul verse.
He's hilarious.
He's the only one of your four horsemen I'd never seen perform.
You don't keep any slob she's around.
I highly recommend your podcasts.
Listeners check out.
There are other shows.
I'd be the water boy.
And this tor to,
I was hoping you were actually a guy in the audience of disguise and you were
going to stand up and rip off your fake mustache and jump up on stage.
Thanks for the podcast and go fuck yourself.
Uh,
there's actually a chance,
um,
then I might pop in on a,
uh,
a show or possibly two on this tour.
You never know,
but just let you know.
Tonight there were helium comedy club,
Great Comedy Club in Portland,
Oregon.
Um,
tomorrow,
Tuesday there at the punchline in San Francisco,
actually Tuesday and Wednesday that the punchline is San Francisco and Thursday
they're at the punchline in Sacramento,
all very outbreak clubs.
It's an amazing show.
They're all my buddies.
I'd love if you had time to go out and support these guys.
The show starts at 8:00 PM.
Um,
see them all on the same bill.
You're going to get to be able to tell your friends that someday.
And uh,
oh.
And also,
um,
Tom Segora,
one of my favorite,
um,
I call them new comedians because I'm an old guy.
And,
um,
he's also one of the members here in the,
uh,
all things comedy network.
He has a new comedy special out his first hour special called completely normal.
It's available if you want to purchase it on iTunes.
If you just want to check it out and get them some views on Netflix,
you can obviously check it out on Netflix.
All right.
I've done one of my mouth here.
Um,
so back to the,
uh,
back to the tour of here.
Um,
they're just realized I'm wearing headphones and I can't even hear myself.
Not that towards back to the,
uh,
the trip up here in France.
Um,
so yeah,
we got here on a Wednesday of last week and uh,
I got to admit,
I haven't seen,
I haven't really done any touristy shit.
Uh,
I just kind of been sitting in cafes,
watching people go and buy,
you know,
eating some great food and I'm riding a bicycle,
riding around like a twinkle toes,
having a good time doing that.
Uh,
walked along the river center.
If you ever get a chance to do that,
um,
you're going to see these stairs that go down where you can get really close to
the river.
Do not,
I repeat,
do not do that.
Um,
I think that's where everyone in Paris,
when they can't make it to the bathroom,
takes a piss because it literally smells like the Ford Authority down there.
If you stay up a pie along the road,
it's incredible.
And um,
I don't know.
We've just been having a great time here.
I'm trying to get,
getting near to come down here to the podcast.
She's still sleeping.
She's got a little bit of jet lag.
Uh,
I don't know.
You know what?
I'll hit pause here in a few minutes and I'll actually go into the other room
and see if I can get her,
I apologize if this is too quiet.
Where's she staying in a very quiet building here.
We um,
we rented an apartment here,
which uh,
it's definitely more expensive,
but it's kind of,
you saved money by basically,
you know,
cause then you have a kitchen.
So what you do,
we should just go down the road,
you know,
you walk outside and you fucking maybe learn some French words on food.
You Go,
where did you go?
Try to have a,
uh,
I tried to go buy your groceries,
all speaking only French.
I was almost saying old to do it.
I fold it,
I can always pull them for the first couple of words and they kind of figure it
out and they slowly start speaking English.
But I kind of just stick with the French,
like I'm trying to learn it at that point I just say,
I'll say the English word and then try to say the French word and then just say,
is that how you say it?
And then they usually correct me or whatever,
but whatever.
Then you could just bring it back,
load up your fridge and I can save a ton of cash that way.
Um,
I dunno.
It's just been amazing.
It's been amazing.
Uh,
I haven't been able to get up early enough to get a fresh baguette.
And,
uh,
I will,
I can tell you that that's something else that I've learned here is nothing,
nothing goes faster than a fucking baguette in the morning,
he's got these people,
like that's one of the true stereotypes.
Like when you see them walking down the street or riding a bicycle with a
Baguette,
these fucking people oriented,
those guys,
them sinks and they tried to be the first person in line.
I mean,
do they,
they,
they're gone.
They're fucking gone by.
Like,
by the time I get up at like 1130 is probably the earliest segment of getting up
around 10 o'clock,
1130 or whatever.
They're just fucking gone.
It's like two or three left.
And,
um,
I dunno.
So,
uh,
I already forget the name of bakery.
I say bake.
We out here.
Ah,
Shit.
I don't know.
But uh,
Neil,
no,
I keep thinking,
I learned words like left Shin and she'd go,
no,
what does she add?
It's like,
ah,
you know what lifts,
fuck you.
You know,
just,
it's kind of annoying because,
you know what,
it actually kind of got pissed a couple of times when she did that to me cause I
felt like I was back in French class.
It's like,
am I ever going to get this shit down?
Um,
so anyways,
as I mentioned that we haven't seen,
the only touristy things that I've seen is I've just stood and looked at him
like the Notradame I basically,
uh,
one day this is a great city to get lost into because you just use the river as
you guide.
MMM.
I just kind of go in about five,
10,
20 blocks,
although you can get lost because of river sort of white river sand kind of
winds down the middle of it.
But it's,
it's been a pretty good way to try to figure out where the hell you're at.
MMM.
But like I walked by the military and it was beautiful and everything,
but I'm not a big religious guy.
And then I saw the line of people outside of it and I just laughed like,
why the fuck?
I understand if you have kids and you're trying to teach them something,
but if you're a fucking adult and you're on vacation,
there's no reason to ever stand in the line.
You're on vacation.
Why would you do that to yourself?
You know,
we were sitting there,
I was trying to find the,
the trials and uh,
I,
I couldn't figure out where the fucking thing was.
It was one of these great moments just wandering around Paris and I saw this
beautiful park and I was just like,
neo,
let's go in there.
It's just walk in there.
She was like,
all right.
So we start walking in and I started to take in the view and I turned around and
I looked over my shoulder
and I was looking right up the shams,
the easy,
however the fuck you say it.
And basically at the end of that street is the Arc de triumph are the way in the
back.
And I literally get goosebumps because all I've ever seen of that monument is
two video footage.
One,
when Hitler,
uh,
when the Germans had defeated France and they were driving up that fucking
street.
And then two,
when,
uh,
England and the Americans came in and we,
help France get the Germans out of their fucking country.
Uh,
all of them,
you know,
all the French women and everybody going fucking crazy.
It really gave me chills.
And I kept saying that to me.
I know I was freaking her out.
There's no way to say Hitler drove up the street in an excited way without
freaking out the person that you're with.
And I had to,
you know,
I'm,
uh,
I liked that history shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like one of the most evil guys ever who was well on his way to taking over
the world and possibly,
you know,
the height of him taking over the,
his quest was him driving up that famous street.
And,
uh,
I don't know.
I'm somebody who got fun.
I was on the road and,
and um,
and Canada,
somebody got me a,
uh,
gave me this book that the guns of August and it's about world war one and it's
phenomenal.
And uh,
I knew that France had lost to Germany in World War One and World War Two
initially,
both wars,
but I didn't realize that in like 1870,
they had had another war in Germany.
One that one.
Ah,
why didn't I bring the book down?
Yeah,
I'll read the quote next week.
And basically France lost France straight up,
lost that war.
It wasn't like World War One,
world war two where they got occupied and then eventually got him out of there.
At least I think that's what happened in World War One.
Cause I,
I don't know much about that world,
but in 1870,
they fucking lost in,
aside from having to give up some land,
one of the things,
part of the treaty and the end is they had to lift the Germans drive up.
That street is sharms and easy.
Right.
And not one French person showed up.
It was one of the darkest days in their history.
I mean talk about absolute fucking humiliation,
right?
So these sons of bitches drive,
drove up the street and uh,
and then they had to pay like,
like some ridiculous amount of Franks as a punishment.
I want to say 5 billion,
but there's no way anybody could afford that back and fucking 1870.
And I'm supposed to take an entire generation for them to pay it back to the
Germans,
which would obviously keep France week and these mother fuckers,
so on of these guys off their back,
they paid it off in three years.
I'm going to go out on the limb and say that nobody ate a Baguette for fucking
three years here in France and they get the Germans off their backs.
And uh,
so once they did,
there was this expression over here,
I guess according to the book anyways,
where basically that moment in their history when the Germans drove up Shawn's
Elisa,
which I'm sure I'm saying it wrong,
uh,
it would basically said,
um,
yeah,
it was something like to never be spoken of,
but always thought about basically never forget that.
Don't bring it up.
That's how,
how much it hurt them to that to happen.
And it was referred to,
uh,
what was it referred to?
I can't remember.
I can't remember as such,
I'm the worst.
Um,
basically I didn't realize it that it happens.
So the fact that fucking Hitler did it again,
I don't know if it happened again in world war one.
I have no fucking idea.
MMM.
So I don't know shit about World War One,
but I happen again.
It will go to,
so it actually happened again.
And uh,
as far as I've gotten into their book,
the guns of August,
basically the fucking reason why
Germany started the first one,
uh,
kind of England and France and everybody else,
they will be in constant to the Germans.
They just wanted to be acknowledged.
They just want it to be included.
So I guess whenever these diplomats would go around Europe and they would visit,
everybody always went to Paris.
Everybody went to fucking Paris because Paris is the shit.
All right.
And people would go to London.
I don't know where the,
maybe they go to Fox in Rome,
but no one ever went to Berlin.
And I guess they started getting this inferiority complex.
Plus there was a couple of treaties going on.
We're just logistically German felt that they were going to have to fight a war
on two fronts and they were going to get fucked.
So unless they
made a move first they were going to be in trouble.
And uh,
you know,
France and England were playing a good,
the great game of what,
we're not going to invade you.
We're not going to try to,
you know,
fucking take over your shit.
Why would we do that?
We're France and England.
We don't have a record of doing that around the fucking world for centuries.
They kind of had an argument,
I'm not to,
I'm talking about world war one here.
I'm not talking about the fucking maniac.
They were World War Two.
I'm just saying,
I actually kind of understood like how,
so that's Kinda that that was their logic.
Let's say it was the right move.
But that was very interesting.
So anyways,
uh,
this is basically what I've been doing here and now today I'm trying to knock
the podcast out,
uh,
early
cause like I said,
we haven't done anything touristy.
We walked,
we walked up,
uh,
the sharms and day that street for a to go see the,
the trials.
And um,
it was funny the first it was a breathtaking street,
but the closer you got to the monument,
the more I felt like I was in times square where,
you know,
there's like a forever 21 and shit like that.
Very disappointing that there was that although I did use a public bathroom that
costs me two euros,
that was the cleanest thing I had ever been to.
Um,
but I didn't realize that,
you know,
you can actually go to the top of that monument.
I had no idea.
And I also still have no idea how you actually get to the monument because it's
in the middle of a fucking rotary and there are subway stairs on the other side.
And we went down into the subway and followed the sign and all it did was spit
us out on the same side.
I couldn't figure it out.
And at the end of the day I have to stand in a fucking line to stand up on
something where I can probably get a taller view,
a higher view at a fucking restaurant at the top of a hotel where there's no
line.
Yeah.
And I can actually look at the monument rather than stand on the monument and
look at a fucking hotel.
It doesn't make any sense.
You want to stand behind fat flux in Jean shorts,
then go to a monument and try to go to the top of it.
I can tell you that.
Anyways,
so then finally me and were like three,
four days here said,
hey,
do you want to look at the Eiffel Tower now?
And she's like,
yeah,
we're both exhausted cause that's a long fucking walk.
Um Oh and by the way,
the way they had this,
their city laid out,
there's like little oomph.
Um,
they're,
they're famous museum with a Mano,
Mona Lisa is,
which I've yet to go see.
I'm going to do that today and right.
Which I don't like the whole setup of it.
How you have,
you have to go in,
you got to go in to see her cause you know,
cause that bitch ain't coming outside.
No,
you gotta you gotta go in and see the fucking thing.
I already know.
I heard it's really small and uh,
you know,
she's got that Ryan Gosling smile.
I'm going to go do it just to fucking do it.
But um,
every day you walk by that there's just bus loads of fucking kids getting
dragged there by their French teachers from around the fucking world.
And you know,
I don't know.
That's why I'm going there on a Monday.
I figured the weekends are going to be worse,
so I'm going to go there and Nia is just like me when it comes to museums.
She likes him for a finite period.
Museums just make me feel dumb.
I'm going,
I'm going to be honest with you.
I go in there and I try.
Okay.
Patrice O'Neal who started this great bit about it was some disaster,
like giant disaster that happened and they were showing all the sad people and
he was talking about how we sat there and he tried so hard to give a fuck.
Um,
which I'm butchering in his delivery of it of course was perfect,
but um,
that's how I feel when I'm,
when I go into a a,
a museum,
the eggs,
the Patrice O'Neal bit where I'm trying so hard to give a fuck.
I just don't care about old stuff.
I respect it.
I would rather hear a scientist.
I'd rather watch a scientist don't television.
Tell me why.
What I'm looking at is so fucking important.
Rather than going up there and have to read the index card,
it's like an index card.
It's like a fucking notebook,
paper size thing of all this shit that just,
there's too much shit to know.
They know I go in there and want to look at the knickknacks of all the fucking
or the boutique up racks,
all of the fucking,
and it's just,
it's too much.
All right.
I like going to car museums,
stuff like that,
you know,
like,
and I can,
I can deal with that.
So I'm not saying museums are bad,
I'm just saying that,
uh,
I am not refined enough as a human being to actually appreciate what's going to
be in that thing.
We'll see.
I'll talk,
I'll talk to you about it next week.
But um,
so anyways,
we had gone to a
mmm.
The Arctic dry off and then,
uh,
I finally go,
all right,
you want to go see the Eiffel Tower?
I mean,
we saw it,
we saw basically a third of it all the way to about a half of it for most parks,
the amazing views.
So we're both tired from walking up the street.
So we got one of those little like Rick Shaw fucking things.
It was the greatest.
So we get jumped in that thing.
We're going on the rotary around the fucking r and a
and we just riding along,
riding along,
riding along.
And then once again,
because the French,
the French know how to make a city.
You go around this roundabout and then all of a sudden there's this,
there's all these buildings and then there's just this giant gap.
And literally I was looking down because I was like videoing as we were riding
and I just heard Nia gasp.
And I looked up in there and there was like,
like a fucking tyrannosaurus rex,
like a giant had just taken up,
you know,
taking a step right towards you.
It was unbelievable.
The greatest tourist attraction I've ever fucking seen.
And I never,
I didn't even go up.
We never went up in it.
We just stood there and looked at it,
um,
essentially from across the river,
but it's right on the river and it's so goddamn big.
It was,
it was incredible.
And then we just went across the way and we sat in a cafe and just,
uh,
just looked at it.
And what's great about the cafes here in France is they,
I'd never been to anything like it.
All the chairs are phased out at the street
off Nini.
I think she just came in.
All the chairs are just faced out at the street cause you just,
you just,
you don't want to miss anything that's going by all these fucking beautiful
women all dressed unbelievably.
Um,
and then you got the Eiffel Tower in the background and we got there just before
dusk and it does,
they turn the lights on.
Oh,
there she is.
Bose.
Yo Madame gonna miss you.
Um,
come on in.
Come on in.
I was smart enough this time to not plug my mixer in right before he stuck it in
the wall with the adapter.
I saw,
I saw the two prong thinks.
I'm like,
wait,
this is what happened to me the last time with my $99 fucking mixer.
We'll come on over here.
Uh,
maybe the,
uh,
the microphone that go,
that means okay.
Everybody,
she has told me she's feeling about it.
Um,
so anyways,
I was just telling them,
what are you talking about?
You just cleared your,
sorry.
See that big blip there?
You just clear it right near the microphone.
Jimmy excused.
Um,
so I was just telling them about taking that Rick shop bike over to the,
uh,
the Eiffel Tower and just how they have the city laid out where you don't see
it,
you don't see,
and then he's just boom,
10 buildings and how he was sitting in that cafe.
Uh,
yeah.
So was an amazing drink wine and I was smoking my little pretentious cigars,
cigarettes,
things.
That's another thing too.
Like everybody fucking smoked over here.
It's hilarious.
It's great.
There's no,
there's no surgeon general here whatsoever.
But uh,
I was mentioning that we're going to go see,
uh,
the Mona Lisa today and I'm not a museum person and I've,
I've kind of been speaking for you on a scale of one to 10,
your,
your feelings about museums.
Hmm.
You know what?
I would say I'm at a seven.
I'm not a full on 10 because I don't,
I'm not the kind of person that's like wants to spend an entire day in a museum.
I want to go in,
see the shift that I want to see and then get out because it's exhausting.
But there are certain things I love.
I love,
I do love museums,
but I just don't want to go there and like,
like when we're in New York and I go to the Moma,
I had,
I just want to go in,
see some things and leave.
I don't want to spend the day at the moment.
Some people do that and they love it.
I can't,
I can't do that.
I literally get sick to my stomach when I hear you say go to the Moma.
What do you mean?
It's just like,
I feel like I'm back in school and it's the class I hate and I have to sit there
until the bell rings.
Do you,
when I was a single
man in New York,
the amount of time people go,
oh,
take it to the museum,
take it to a museum.
And it would always is the worst fucking date.
And it was,
and I would do it because people say that,
you know,
that's where you take these New York ladies.
So right.
Then I would take them there like I was culture and that culture and I would go
there and I'd be bored shitless and then they would feel it.
Like I'm telling like 20 minutes,
15,
20 minutes depending on how good looking she was.
1520 minutes in,
I would be,
I would just be bored shitless at what you'd be looking for,
for a place to buy a hot dog.
But the thing is there's certain,
there'll be certain exhibits that museums that you would like.
Remember when we went to the car museum?
I said good,
I liked the car museum.
You're like that.
I like uh,
I liked there was like a standup comedy exhibit.
Yeah.
That's not a museum.
That's just cool shit.
Or like a bunch of cool photographs I could get into.
Right.
But the uh,
the,
the artifacts,
like when we went to,
we went to the,
the fucking thing there,
I was on the ceiling.
That shit was just shovel.
You were like black walking through there.
Like you were walking through an airport trying to get to your gate.
You were like walking so fast.
Barely looking at anything.
You were just like,
I'm just walking through this because I just have one cause it's the Sistine
chapel.
It was one vista mall vestments after another.
This beautiful,
no,
what are you talking about?
It Wa I know we have this whole,
I can't even believe that you would say that.
It's not beautiful in there.
It was absolutely gorgeous.
It was a lot to take in,
but you're,
you're like,
what?
13 year old boy.
You're like,
this is boring.
It looks like you look like an Italians living room.
You know that Hacky joke that they do where they talk about that room that's all
covered in plastic that no one can go into.
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
It's just ornate.
I'm going to use the word [inaudible] so fucking over.
It was so gaudy.
Every look,
you know how you love how the Parisian stress where it's basically all dark
color,
all dark color,
and then like the splash of color with the scarf or the shoes or the hat and
everything else is sorta,
it was it,
was it muted,
Matte,
neutral,
whatever the fucking word is.
Um,
that was the exact opposite.
Yeah.
That was the epitome of,
oh,
but look,
no,
but there's so much time and skill that goes into putting all those frescoes up.
It was absolutely incredible though.
You got to appreciate that part of it.
You gotta be shade the artistry that goes into something like the same way I can
appreciate an older movie,
but also realize that the dialogues a little dated,
like the way they decorated it.
There's a little dated.
Oh,
I've got to give what,
what does it,
what do you mean dated?
I mean it's,
it's Rome.
It's one of the oldest cities.
I love Rome.
I loved Rome.
I loved everything about it.
Other than that fucking the only museum I went to was a stupid Sistine chapel.
And it's sucked when you go there and make a right and go go right to the
ceiling painting and then get the fuck outta here.
Don't go to the left and see every chalice they ever fucking drank out of for
like the next.
And it wasn't even crowded that day.
God forbid if it was fucking crowded,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
I swear to God you're going to think about abandoning your family for good is
your,
if you're wired like me.
Um,
so by the way,
uh,
okay.
I would now say having been here that uh,
Paris,
as far as Europe goes,
yes.
Paris is like New York City.
I'd say London.
It's like a smart Chicago.
I love saying that just to piss off people in Chicago
and then Rome is sort of like a Boston Philly kind of thing.
You know what?
I really feel like it's a complete like travesty that you would try to compare
these amazing European cities to cities in the United States.
Oh,
gimme of the city,
New York,
Chicago and Boston painted them said like Europe.
Like that's stupid.
Well most of my listeners to do that,
most of my listeners are from the United States of America.
They need,
they need a frame of reference when I'm doing,
you don't need to give them some sort of like water down frame of reference like
no,
Paris
and Rome is like Rome.
Jesus.
Yeah,
you got to do that person who comes over here and now fucking just says that
everything over here is,
is like is paid with gold.
No,
I'm not saying you see all those suspicions.
Shipping jackasses and England.
I mean you can't tell me that.
That's not Chicago.
Like the monopod,
the checks and I had an awesome time so I honestly,
I don't know that much about,
I love Chicago.
I love Chicago and I gave London props or I said that it's like a smarter
Chicago plus.
I like Chicago.
That's what I go through with.
Somebody has to go down in the scenario.
Sorry Chicago.
Oh fuck you.
I love Chicago.
When you would go,
me,
I'm a moron that,
but I bought the totally been doing this.
Talk about dumb.
I am on this.
I can't even go to a fucking museum and enjoy myself.
Um,
oh,
so also out here,
um,
oh,
you know what you missed yesterday.
You missed these two.
Uh,
I was going to say French people like,
like what else are they out here?
These two French guys.
Oh,
that's another thing too.
Uh,
uh,
just like in,
in what I love about traveling,
just the,
but just like in Philly,
I would,
cheese steak is just called the cheese steak.
They don't go,
can I get a Philly cheese steak there in Philly?
Just like over here.
French toast is not French toast to put pound per do I do that part,
but that's what it is.
There's no French in it.
They are French.
They don't need to say it.
So that's my travel.
It's delicious.
It's wasn't a really good with that customer.
Although in Boston it's still a Boston cream pie says cause it's Boston.
Yeah,
we're more on
that where we are.
Oh,
I happen to have a login,
Framingham,
whatever.
Over there they got to do a fight.
Everything in Boston,
just to say that it's Boston related.
Oh,
shut up.
It's not like Boston.
I love my city,
but come on Boston is you want to talk about dumb,
let's talk about Boston.
What are you talking about?
How you know we have Harvard,
Boston universities.
I went to college and plastic.
It's a wonderful,
uh,
Mecca of university,
University of people who come from other places
to continue their education in a very,
uh,
beautiful risk fall setting.
Otherwise I would,
it's a bunch of Jack as is as you say.
I would be,
I would be offended by that if I didn't fit into that fucking story.
Believe it or not,
people,
I did not get accepted to Harvard.
I got accepted to Wentworth.
Wentworth was a construction.
Uh,
what is this is like,
this is like fucking breakfast club when I'm dumb because I know how to make a
lamp.
No,
you're not.
you're a genius because you how to make a left.
That's what you supposed to say.
And I had no construction skills
whatsoever.
The reason why I picked it was because it just looked like it was a fun job
because I was working in warehousing and I noticed when you worked with a bunch
of other guys in the boss was sort of there but not really there.
You could just stand around breaking balls all day.
So that's why I picked the school.
Right.
Okay.
I get accepted there and then I also got semi accepted to northeastern.
Like all right,
we'll let you take,
we'll let you take a couple of classes.
So yeah,
you'd do.
And yeah,
it was a fucking nightmare.
And then I went to,
I went to neither place I got,
I got rejected from Harvard of course,
cause I wasn't smart enough.
My Dad went to Harvard,
so I thought like,
well let me apply to Harvard.
I feel like I should have your family a big harder to get into Harvard.
But I didn't.
And I went to Emerson and it was awesome.
So is there is my college story and that's my college story.
What,
coming up on an hour here.
Uh,
what do you,
what are you talking about here?
I talk about
it's about everything.
Oh,
you know,
something else I've been trying like every frigging cigar,
uh,
that you can try out here because of selection is incredible.
But this is what I have learned.
Even in Paris.
If you want to buy a cigar,
go to a cigar store.
What's the one that I went to down the street.
A Ruth
on way?
Yeah.
You got to go to a specialty place.
Just like with the,
uh,
the belongs only you go to Boulogne jewelry.
That's bakery.
Yeah,
to get the salt and the baguettes and I guess you go to a patsy salary to get
the like little cakes and macaroons and things like that.
Yeah,
because
then that what's you,
you just going to get ripped off?
Like it's weird because they got all these places.
Is it just,
it was his t a,
B,
a c tobacco.
The Buck?
Yes.
You just see those signs and you're like,
oh,
this Cuban cigars in there and you walk in there but they don't know what the
fuck they're doing.
Like,
I walked in to one yesterday and I bought two different size,
like Cohibas,
the smaller ones and real thin ones and uh,
he's supposed to like,
basically what you do is you squeeze the end of it.
He's supposed to go in about 50% and that's supposed to come back out
and like smushed watching you squeeze your imaginaries.
Yeah,
the cigar,
regardless of how hard it is,
it doesn't make a difference.
It's that right there that'll give you a good drop at the whole thing was Swiss
squishy and I noticed that they seemed almost a little wet.
They had the fucking humidifier up too high.
And I'm sitting there,
I was smoking it last night.
It was like,
you know,
I was like,
I'm smoking wet leaves.
It just,
and it was a Cuban,
it was,
I had to finish the thing.
How funny it was.
It when I stuck the Qtip in the end of it to the science.
So I get down there yet it was still,
you know,
better than any cigar that I usually get it.
Yeah.
It's like when you're like in college or whatever and you're trying to smoke
like the very smallest part of the joint,
you use a pair of tweezers to smoke out of it.
That was it.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's a French club.
There's a famous
story,
cause I've only heard it once in my life.
I'm not going to sell it.
It's famous.
Uh,
Castro,
when he was at the UN,
he actually lit up during the whole meeting of the minds of people around the
world.
And as he's sitting there listening,
he's smoking a Cuban,
which I think is a big fuck you to the u s like,
yeah,
you guys wish you could be smoking these.
And in the end he,
he,
what?
He uses a roach clip was some part of his glasses.
He's stuck it in there and he was holding his glasses,
like hitting it like a at yeah.
Huh.
Dressed like he was on [inaudible]
Mash.
Um,
I got you a question from the blue.
Long jury.
Okay.
What flavor plane?
The butter one.
How do you say it?
Be?
Um,
okay,
let's read a couple of these things here.
Uh,
fake sports enthusiasm.
Um,
dear Billy balls between the final four and the Superbowl,
which one do you think attracts the most fake female sports fans?
All just running out the door and whatever color they are rooting for it.
Never watched any regular season games,
which is it?
I say the final four.
Uh,
first of all,
I don't think that you got to just say that it's women.
Uh,
yeah.
Fuck you announce Jesus.
I'm not saying that because Nia is here either.
Otherwise I might subconsciously,
because we have to spend the day,
the most fake female sports fans.
There's only fake female sports friends.
I would say,
oh,
I would put the Superbowl is brutal for the fake female sports fair.
It's fucking brutal because
most people pretend like they give a shit about the Superbowl when they don't.
They just want to watch the goddamn commercials.
That's a,
that's a very ignorant point of view of what you're doing right now because
you're looking at your own head and saying,
this is the view of the world to put things in the,
at your part.
A lot of people are.
I didn't say you're part of the problem.
You're the woman who shows up that doesn't give a fuck and touch,
you know,
I don't go to games or any of that kind of shit with you because I had usually
don't care.
No,
no bumps so but the Superbowl you do show up,
you go to a Superbowl party,
eat the food you top during the game,
shut up during the commercial and then when the game comes back on you got added
that God,
haven't you think that one?
Because that one wasn't that good.
That is not what I do at all.
Don't ever do that.
That more barest then on super bowl Sunday with you and I've never done that.
I usually dip out during the game or I'm sort of sitting there watching it and
not really paying attention or if you're over in the corner giggling with your
friends during the game.
All I hear is ha ha.
Now
I would actually say the super bowl because the super bowl has become like a
national holiday and it's the fact that it is one day.
It is on the weekend.
It's only just for one fucking day.
And uh,
the fact that there's going to be food and all of that stuff for non sports fans
to still enjoy.
Um,
and then all the other extra fucking hyping like,
oh,
we need to turn the channel and watch the puppy bowl or whatever the fuck it is
or yeah.
Oh my God.
That's cute.
It's fucking Bruno Mars is going to be playing at halftime.
He did kill a,
he's awesome.
Killed it.
He's awesome.
I'm not saying he didn't,
but I'm just saying better than Tom.
Petty.
Tom Petty.
Tom Petty came out looking like the guy in the Nichols.
Oh,
that.
Yeah.
The bond last dance and maybe that guy.
Yeah,
he looked literally,
who's the guy in the Nicole stuff?
Thomas Jefferson or Thomas Jefferson or a Tom Petty.
Tom Petty.
All right.
Girlfriend.
Cheating on her diet.
Really written off.
Um,
why you don't like that delivery now that's actually a very funny girlfriend.
Cheating Dat.
Dat Dat on her,
on a diet.
That sounds like a gay guy wrote that order diet.
Um,
ridiculous.
Scandalous.
I'm up 27 years old and have a girlfriend of six years whom I live with.
When we first got together,
she had a sexy athletic body that all changed last year when she got promoted,
started working long hours in a high stress position.
Uh,
she began smoking weed almost every night claiming it to help you relax after a
hard day's work.
And she also started eating like Shit,
lost of lots of fast food,
larger portions,
et cetera.
She's probably 60 to 70 pounds heavier than when we first met and on her five
three frame if fucking shows,
man,
after ignoring my sub,
that would show on a six foot frame after my,
after ignoring my suddenly 60 to 70 pounds heavier.
After ignoring my subtle hints for the last year,
I finally sat her down last month and said,
enough is enough.
She needs to make an effort to get healthier.
I did everything.
Does this support her and losing weight.
I paid for an expensive supplement program that are co workers recommended.
I started making her healthy lunches every day to take to work when she get home
from work.
I'd have a healthy dinner ready for on the table.
I even paid for a new gym membership and bought her a new bicycle.
Today I found a hidden cachet of fast food wrappers in the garage.
This led me to believe to look at our bank statements from the last month.
She's been picking up fast food on her way home from work nearly everyday since
we talked.
It sounds like a biggest loser story.
Not only that,
she'd also buy fast food at lunches sometimes to suggesting that she was tossing
the lunches.
I made her in the trash.
This really pissed me off.
I'm a guy who takes care of my body and one a woman who does the same.
She's only 24 and hasn't had children.
She shouldn't have a beer,
gut jowls and saggy tits.
The
Oh you are so in the pocket you sold as the take your computer and throw it out
the goddamn window.
Can you please finish the rest of this so I can go off on this asshole please
just put an issue because I swear to fucking God.
I swear to God.
I think he's making a lot of good points.
He,
oh my God.
The fact that I spent my God,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Don't scream two pumps too close to the computer.
I don't use a mixture of this week.
The fact that I spent all this time,
money and effort on her,
only to have her sabotage it and hide it from me makes me seriously call our
relationship into question.
What would you do?
My situation?
Oh my God.
And he was taking off her shoes.
You know what?
No one has to be core.
No,
I know.
I you know what you shallows,
bullshit.
Fucking asshole guy who wrote this letter.
Let me explain something to you right now.
You think you care about her health?
You don't care about her health.
You certainly don't care about her state of mind.
All you care about is whether or not your girlfriends hot enough.
What for you?
For your friends,
for society.
You don't give a shit.
You said yourself,
she's got this job.
She's stressed out and so she's stressed eating.
That's what a lot of people do.
Okay,
and you're sitting here,
you seem like you were well intentioned.
Right?
But now it seems like you're just being fucking shallow because you don't care.
You don't care about anything that's going on inside of her physically or
mentally or emotionally.
All you care about is what she looks like and now you're mad because she's like
hiding it from you.
And you're calling into question of relationships.
You've been with her for six years.
Collins or question,
her relationship,
how she feels about you because she's going through something emotional.
Why do you talk to her about how she feel?
Because I was trying to put a bandaid on the problem and making it seem like the
care when you obviously don't give a shit.
Okay,
you're a shallow superficial Douche bag and she should dump your ass and get
hot.
Even hotter than white.
And she's 2040 minutes.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Time out.
Time out now,
how would she go about getting even hotter?
Okay.
By losing 60 to 70 pounds,
you know what?
She could get hotter by finding a guy who was making more money and who was
nicer and like,
uh,
just a better approach.
You should become a gold digging fat whore.
No,
no.
Wait a minute.
Now listen,
listen.
Here's the
forgot her.
Even if I'm being too hot.
I'm gonna tell you right now.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Better body when she's a teenager,
she was,
when she started to get into like her,
what a surprise.
I'm out.
Unbelievable.
Oh my God.
When people get older and have like grownup responsibilities,
that's,
that's really crazy how that happened.
So you,
you,
you hit,
you hit the,
and you've got what?
Like a six pack and a full head of hair and you're just like the hottest guy
ever.
Right?
And that's not going to change for you.
And maybe in 10 years,
if you go through something and you're having a hard time and the person that
you are supposedly love and cares about you and has been with you for six years,
just decides to what toss you aside because you gained some weight
barbecue.
Wait a minute.
Okay,
timeout.
Kay.
Can I defend this guy a little bit more?
Sure.
That's what you do.
You defend the assholes who right into you.
So go ahead.
Well,
I can't bite the hand that feeds.
No,
I'm,
I'm not defending this
guys just to defend this guy.
Okay?
First of all,
you're ignoring the fact that this guy,
he sat down with her in a nice way,
okay,
okay.
In a caring way,
Nia,
to be five foot three and put it on 60 to 70 pounds and you're setting yourself
up for heart disease and you're going to die.
And this guy,
and she hasn't even had kids yet.
Okay.
Timeout.
And she has to go to all of that,
which,
you know,
Nia.
Okay.
You like,
that's,
that's already hard enough as it,
she's only 24 years old.
You should not be 60 to 70 pounds or 30 pounds.
Overweight is obese.
This girl is,
is two times on a way to three times at 24th,
she's blowing out her body and she's,
she's never going to be in shape again and she's going to live a miserable
fucking life because a very difficult life because of it.
She's going to blow at our knees up telling you all of this is going to come.
And this guy,
he did not sit down and say,
hey,
you used to be hot and now you're not.
He said,
time out.
No,
he isn't the way a timeout timeout.
He sat down with her like an adult and said that basically I'm concerned about
you.
Um,
you know,
we say I love you.
I'm concerned about you.
I want to help you get healthier.
This guy is making lunches for,
he's paying for a gym,
he's doing all of this stuff.
And in the end when he's trying to help her out and then she's going behind his
hurt,
his back eating,
which she's doing it out of a shame thing,
he felt betrayed and then the anger comes out and then that's when he says beer
got jowls and saggy tests.
Okay,
now this is the thing there,
like it's unnecessary for him so I put it like I understand what you're saying.
Well he has to because he can't say that to her when he can't get,
he has to get his anger out or he has to make a fucking joke.
He has to do something and here this guy is also 27 years old.
He says he keeps himself from fucking shape,
which you know something that's not fair to your part and it's not fair to the
apartment to go out and put on that kind of weight.
Okay.
If he's 24 years old,
those she can bounce back.
It's not like she's 44 she's 24 okay.
Like I know that hard to lose that kind of weight of course,
but she can do it.
But I'm just saying like
he's doing all this stuff or are you like do all like the physical stuff,
but he seems like he's incapable of being like emotionally support her because
he talking about he was,
yeah,
he was in the beginning.
He wasn't the beginning.
He did this.
What he's doing in the end is he's talking to me,
guided guy.
She's 24 years old,
has he had kids,
she shouldn't have a beer,
gut Giles and saggy.
You know he's coming out of like a football coach.
Well,
she doesn't need a football coach.
He didn't he say it to her.
He said it to me suggesting she was tossing the lunches.
I made her in the trash.
Yeah.
Who knows.
She might have,
she might have just is probably even a both.
She's probably right.
What would you do with my situation that helped this fucking guy out?
He seems like he's keeping himself in shape.
He's fit.
He's actually a great boyfriend.
If he was a dick,
he would have said,
I'm breaking up with you because she had a beer gut and jealous.
He didn't.
He tried to help her with the fucking problem guys,
problem solve.
Okay.
Help this guy connect with her emotionally.
So I mean,
look,
she's got this high stress fucking job,
but like at some point,
you know,
you got to settle into the stress of your job where you'd have to get a new
fucking job.
But this is what it's doing to you.
All right.
I mean,
I got to tell you,
you get 60 to 70 pounds overweight at 24 fucking years of age.
What's going to happen in 34 and yet that is a legitimate question.
It's a legitimate question because that weight thing is,
you know,
it starts happening.
People died.
Mia,
not to bring up a bad fucking subject,
like taking it to the extreme though.
I mean,
you're going to think about being with somebody for rest of their life.
You're going to have kids with this person.
They're already this much overweight.
They're not going to be be there.
They're not going to fucking be there.
All right,
fine.
Maybe I went too far and when I was calling him an asshole and all that kind of
stuff,
man.
Thank you.
What a normal reaction.
Yeah,
it's that last,
that last thing.
You know what I mean?
Because you know what?
You're right.
Everything that he says that he's doing in terms of making your healthy meals
and buying her bike to the gym membership,
that's all well and good.
And maybe that's,
this is the part about men and women.
That's difficult because yes,
you guys try to problem solve.
You don't try to connect on an emotional level and say like bury the emotions.
Right?
You go to the gym exactly where like it sounds like what she needs,
she needs to blow off steam and a lot of people do.
They eat,
they drink,
they smoke weed,
they do other drugs.
This is how they cope.
These are how people cope.
It's another thing,
uh,
an alcohol,
a drug,
but now she's,
no,
we then that increases your hunger for most people.
Like,
like you wouldn't believe so and all and you don't want a salad when you're
high,
you want pizza.
And she was Burberry Nachos.
Let me ask you this.
Let's just say you're dating.
All right.
You know,
we've been going out for two years.
I'm in great shape and then all of a sudden the stress of the robe,
I put on 60 to 70 pounds and start smoking weed.
Now you're going to tell me that you're not going to entertain breaking up with
me.
You're not going to sit there and be like,
this is going to be the father of my kids.
This is the person who I spend my life with.
This guy was acting like he's in fucking Wayne's world and a uncle buck all at
the same time.
You know what?
I honestly can't say that I would.
If you all of a sudden that's all you were doing with yourself and whenever you
weren't on the road will just sitting around smoking weed.
And you know what?
If I came home a magic my pasty freckle torso with man text.
Hmm.
Right.
Fucking naval.
The size of a half dollar now.
Yeah.
Smoking weed and just sitting there fucking,
you know,
that's going to affect my sex drive.
Getting on top of your
sweating all over me.
You've got to get on top of me.
I look like I'm pregnant.
I mean,
give me a fucking break.
And then you're walking down the street and you're seeing all these other guys
go to the gym.
I would that you're in the prime of your fucking life and you're going to pick a
mate for the rest of your fucking life,
and I'm already looking like I've worked on Wall Street the 30 fucking years.
You're not going to sit there and have any second thoughts come on yet.
I mean,
I might not be as sexually attracted to you,
that's for sure,
but I wouldn't just,
or the bandaid off and just say what you're going to say,
but I wouldn't be like I need to.
I,
that's the other thing that I have a problem.
This is a problem that I have,
especially with this whole letter.
The fact that I spent all this money and effort on only to have her sabotage it
and hide it for me,
makes me seriously call our relationship into question.
Why does that call your relationship into questions?
Deceptive?
Yeah,
because she's going through some emotional shit,
but she's been receptive about food.
It's not like she's like cheating on it.
She's like,
you know what?
I know.
She goes,
I know she is to make it,
to see him like,
you know,
oh,
or do you really not love me now?
Because you know you're not following this diet that we agree that you would
like.
That's not,
that's not a fair comparison to make on somebody.
Like that's not,
it's really not fair to do that.
No,
it's,
is it fair to do what she's going?
Well,
it's,
she's not doing it against like against him and as,
as a way to hurt him.
I know she has.
So you can't see,
you can't say is it fair for her to be doing that to him?
But this was this classic fucking female thing.
We,
you guys are right when you're right and you're right when you're wrong.
Like you're acting like she's doing this to hurt him.
Well,
why can't she be a little more mature?
Just we've just say like,
listen,
why can't she sit down with him and just level with him and let him know?
Just say,
listen,
I gotta be honest with you.
I know that you care about me.
I know that you sat down and you had this,
this conversation with me and I know that I said going to do this,
this and this,
but I'm actually doing that and I'm actually not going to the gym and I feel bad
that you're wasting your money and all that and you're taking all this time to
make a lunch every morning.
How loving is that that he's doing that?
She shouldn't do that.
All right then she's not 100% free of guilt.
The thing about it is Nia,
is that guys are guys,
and we talk like guys and guys just get to the fucking heart of the matter.
I don't want it that bad.
What is it?
He looked at her bank statements from last module,
pick up fast food on her way nearly every day.
I gotta tell you.
Yeah,
that's a chick thing to do.
Go through somebody's email and snoop.
Yeah,
no it is.
It's snow.
But now you know you don't like that.
And then what if a woman did?
You probably wouldn't like it.
No,
I don't.
I she,
she had a hunch.
No I don't.
I have friends who checks.
Right.
And I don't,
I don't think it's smart to do.
I think it's ridiculous.
And also it's like don't look cause you more than likely going to see something
that you don't want to be checking your emails later on.
Yeah,
I have nothing to hide all my doing a situation.
Well first of all I should probably apologize for saying fuck you and calling
you an asshole.
Um,
but yeah,
you should just have sit down and have a talk with her and just say I'm
concerned about you and what's,
what's going on with you emotionally?
Like tell me what's going on.
How does he deal with,
maybe we can like go for a walk after work and you can tell me about your day
when he wakes up,
when he brings up the fact that he snooped and looked at a bank state does not
need to do that.
Well let's just do,
let's just say he does cause at this point now his girlfriend,
because she's going to freak out and she can get a lot of weight behind those
punches now.
Um,
now he should just say,
I'm worried about you because I feel like you're,
you're going through some stuff and I tried to help you,
but maybe it's not enough.
Do you want to talk to me?
Do you want to talk to somebody else?
How do you,
how are you feeling?
Cause she probably feels about herself.
She probably feels terrible about herself.
She's gained that much weight.
None of her clothes fit anymore.
She knows how she looks.
She probably feels absolutely terrible.
And her one solves is that she's got this boyfriend who's home and he cares
about her and he loves her and she's abuser.
That's not,
you don't throw that word around take long.
We're just taking an amazing him.
She's taking advantage,
taking advantage of their love.
She's not,
you're making it.
That's what I don't.
So she's not trying to hurt him by doing that.
She's hurting.
And you don't know him.
Exactly.
So why are you writing?
And I'm wrong.
I'm not,
I'm not saying I'm right.
I'm giving you my IP.
Isn't that why I'm here?
You really have a beautiful profile,
you know?
Um,
don't try to throw me upstairs anyway.
Shade them,
but don't try to throw me off.
All right.
That wasn't legitimate thought,
but I was trying to throw you off.
No,
listen if,
um,
listen fucker,
I was going to say
it would be very hard for a what we were just talking about.
No,
she probably feels bad for herself.
She's probably blah,
blah blah.
Here's something.
What if she doesn't?
What if she doesn't give a fuck all those people,
how do you know there aren't those people just don't give a fuck cause she's a
woman.
She's five,
three and just put on more than like 10 pounds,
which is,
it's just devastating for that.
I'm five,
four and I have been,
what about 25 pounds heavier?
I understand.
They'll look good though.
You lays me when I was a little bit heavier.
Yeah,
I would say,
I don't want to say you liked it when I was a little bit thicker.
So listen,
I under his eye and it does show it.
It shows like nobody's business.
You are right sir.
It,
it shows,
um,
and to have your formerly tight hot body girlfriend all of a sudden not be that
way.
I know.
And she looks,
she looks like she's a retired athlete in her 50s,
at 24.
I mean,
what is he supposed to do?
He gets 27 so what,
so he is still at that shallow age where he's like,
you know,
calling into question is relationship based on your partner's weight gain?
No.
That,
that's,
that's the level of maturity.
And he's at,
they had,
that's yeah.
Listen,
that's a very serious fucking thing to be that,
that overweight at that age.
I mean,
if you do that to your body and you stay that way for 20 years,
I mean it's
okay.
Your body can only take that for so long.
And when you're thinking about starting a family with somebody,
they have to be around.
They got to be involved.
They can't be over in the corner,
you know,
with no energy,
lethargic and,
and,
and then have on top of that all kinds of fucking hell.
That's another thing too.
Yeah.
You're not gonna be able to get fucking health insurance
mean.
What she's doing is really is effective.
Both of them,
I'm not trying to be a dick here,
but like they're not even engaged though.
This is his girlfriend.
That's how you get is really lose weight.
You should propose.
So please wait with the quickness.
Just me.
I know.
Yeah.
But then once they get married,
she's going to go right back to Doritos.
Yeah.
Well then that just,
that just means that there is a,
a significant emotional thing that needs to be addressed.
So all that stuff that you did while you got,
um,
this great bike in a gym membership and all that stuff to support,
first of all,
that should,
that should tell you that a person is only going to change their lifestyle if
they want to.
Number one.
That's the first lesson.
That's what drugs or food or anything.
Number two,
that that means you need to go deeper than just the kind of like these are the
things they do and get healthy.
That means they're either talking or you're suggesting therapy or you go to
therapy to talk to talk about it or something.
She probably needs to,
if she's got like some sort of like eating,
I have food addiction or something,
I got the,
you know,
she's probably just fucking depressed.
When you're depressed,
you smoke weed and you gain weight.
Like she's depressed,
he needs stressed out.
He needs to sit down and decide if it's worth it.
If this,
does he love this person enough to ride through this fucking store?
If,
if,
if you're not,
if you don't feel that way,
then you should just walk.
Okay.
And then,
okay.
Breaking her heart is better than marrying her and when you don't love her.
So just break her heart.
The stress of that and the sadness of that.
She won't even be able to eat that big king every day and should probably drop
like 15
it has.
He has,
he stopped loving her
because if that's the case,
then he's calling their relationship into question.
So I don't know why,
because he's being honest.
Why can't you fucking be honest?
Why can't guys be these deep who we are we,
we are visually you don't.
I love about women is you fucking want to use that shit where visually
attractive gets you a fucking drink or get your get your honest centric.
What do you mean?
Like that doesn't fucking work.
You want to use it when it works for you and then you want to,
you want to use that weakness when it's to your fucking advantage.
And then once the other way,
you want us to be these fucking understanding God damn people,
okay.
Want us to be guys,
when it gets you a free fucking drink.
We want guys to love us.
Whether we're like the hot body or we gained some weight.
That's what we want.
We want some 90 that you want your cake and eat.
No,
we want,
we want to live in a world where we don't have to even fucking have this
conversation.
That's what I want to be rude and fat in,
in,
in Shell job.
Actually do whatever I want to do.
You're rude and fat and disgusting and ridiculous and you get to do that.
Well,
women can't do that.
As you went to Rup mic,
we have to be like the hot body.
Otherwise you call our relationship into question.
Oh,
so this one guy is,
everybody know he's not everybody,
but we're just,
we're talking about just a general,
you know what you just said.
Women like to do this and women like to do that.
Like it's all women.
That's what I do.
Yeah.
But I'm a moron.
You're supposed to be a higher being you a female.
We are higher beings.
You're not just us.
Not just as dumb as we are,
just of different areas.
You know.
You don't think so.
No.
Being him being an emotional person,
it makes you tuned in to things that you as a male with your basic fucking
basicness can't understand.
So we already are high and we can like carry children.
We've got some spiritual level shit that you'll never understand.
Exactly.
And you know,
we also have,
we have some plow through some shit that you don't understand
that you don't understand.
Loudly.
Associate an emotion finish of fucking thought.
No.
Yeah,
you have.
Can you be a plow through shit and an emotional,
you need both of those things,
don't you think?
Yeah,
it's called the ying and the Yang,
but for some reason you think your Yang is better than my Yang and that's the
fucking problem.
And it's 50,000 shows on fucking TV.
As much as you ladies complain about the images on TV.
This is zillion fucking things on TV that are telling you that you guys are
right and guys are morons.
Start with 90% of the fucking advertising when they show a man and a fucking
woman in a relationship like that ridiculous one from a few years ago that I'll
never fucking believe that they were actually where she's sitting at the
computer and the guys outside finds a beehive and literally sticks a broom
handle up into the fucking thing and it's getting stung by bees cause he's a
dumb guy and she has to sit down and handle the family business at the fucking
computer.
Okay,
please do the female,
the chauvinist Dick version of that fucking commercial.
What do you mean?
Do show a sip version that
when they'll have the guy that's the guy
figuring out the family business on a fucking computer.
Is she sitting there a lot of looking through a fashion magazine or that's just
not selling,
but at the same level of ridiculousness.
What is the female version of sticking a broom handle?
Lindell fucking beehive.
They're assuming that the woman is taken care of like the day to day run the
household stuff that the man is trying to be working.
No.
So there wasn't a metaphor.
So they're trying to appeal to a woman's so that
she'll like the product and then she'll buy it.
It's all like,
what about Savannah market?
No,
it is not like,
what about the metaphor that's going on there?
That he's such a moron.
He's trying to stick his fucking pull into any goddamn yeah.
Holy Cow.
That's not knowing.
Not knowing you can get stung at anymore.
Yeah.
I was him getting herpes.
Uh dear Billy bounce.
What music are you listening to these days?
What's on your iPod?
What's the lovely Neil listening to?
What do you listen to when you work out?
Chiseled,
meet Marvin Body.
It's as old as Lee Marvins party.
Um,
what am I listening to these days?
I don't fucking know.
Okay.
What am I usually listen to shift that makes me want to play drums,
uh,
or learns some drunk shit.
So I have no idea what's last night he actually watched,
we're watching comedy central because we weren't,
we were,
uh,
their website.
Like jet lag.
Yeah.
I couldn't sleep.
And when I watch key and Peele and I watched the workaholics and a broad city,
when I watched all that did was make me feel fucking old.
It made me feel fucking old.
Like,
uh,
I mean I love let me get back.
So they're all fucking hilarious.
Like I was legitimately left laughing through all of that,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
But I didn't get,
I didn't get so much of this shit not going to get it.
Like what was that thing that handle Burress thing that he said?
I didn't even get it.
Oh yeah.
He was talking about Childish Gambino,
Donald Glover.
It was an interview with nerve.com that handle birthday and it was like we asked
and Hannibal Burress for sex advice and in the end they would ask him if he
would want to do like a mix tape and if you wrap this and now he's like,
yeah,
I thought about it but I'm not going to,
you know,
go for like childish Gambino and this and that and the other.
And then he made a reference to like,
you know,
oh,
we figured out like childish Gambino,
Israeli,
like bill bird and that's it.
That's done.
Or like when he does stand up and you just could not understand,
no matter how many times I tried to explain to you what was he making fun.
Is that a,
is that a compliment that Donald was,
that Donald Glover is also childish Gambino or you just didn't eat,
didn't seem to,
it's the whole time I heard Donald Glover,
all I was picturing was Danny.
Yeah,
no,
and it's Donald Glover.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
And then the Kroll show,
Jesus Christ.
Everything on the Kroll show is hilarious.
I mean going on,
what am I listening to since they were asking you when is a lovely meal?
Listen to,
um,
I actually downloaded Sam Smith album based on his performance when Lucy kids
did SNL.
Actually it was another recent appearance that alluded.
It wasn't the first time around.
Um,
so Sam Smith is awesome.
Just has a beautiful voice.
I'm actually been making a lot of mixes of like old stuff,
a lot of old hip hop.
I've been listening to a lot like nineties.
I love that though.
What makes hip hop hip hop?
Um,
but I love,
I love,
um,
what's the like the latest like maybe um,
Pusha t his album is like,
it's something that I listened to her lover.
I have no idea who I played.
I played it for you.
You liked a couple of his,
his versus,
but overall,
I don't think you were into it cause you're not really into hip like rap music
right now.
Okay.
Right.
Would you say
I,
you know,
I can't get,
I can't listen to it.
If you're going to fucking walk around your house or your apartment,
talking about all this stuff that you have in there,
it's just boring as shit to me.
Um,
I like storytellers.
I will never like those,
those guys that tell stories,
you know about guns and selling drugs if it's actually real.
It sounds real.
Like they actually did.
That's why I love Jay z and Biggie because they actually did that shit and then
they talked about it and it was like listening to a movie.
I liked that stuff.
Um,
you know,
but she don't like,
I don't like,
I don't [inaudible] was so far up his own ass.
I,
it's just like,
it's true.
Yeah.
I never heard of like,
who walks around called himself a genius.
Who does that?
I mean this like right there.
You're not a genius.
You're an idiot.
Like I don't,
and I don't understand what it,
I hate when he also stretches out the words.
It's like,
what are you trying to dumb it down for me?
You either don't have enough material for this fucking song to finish it.
It's a style.
It's like,
Eh,
you know,
what do you
get the fucking one that I listened to cause they're like,
oh my God.
Talking about being apropos.
It's,
I believe it's called Edwards in Paris.
Yes.
Um,
in Paris.
Uh,
yeah,
there's a part of the film where he stretches out like Jay z kills it and then
he comes on any starts,
we get married at the mom or dad they deal with.
Uh,
and it just keeps going and going and going like,
and I just feel like,
and it stinks.
It's not clever and he's slowing it down like I'm supposed to be on the other
end.
I'm like,
oh
well whatever.
I'm sure a Zillion,
Tanya can't be wrong.
He's a genius.
Saint Vincent as another one.
I guess the most contemporary thing
I've listened to in the past couple of years is probably not the new math.
And that's the only,
because Andrew who does the podcast told me to check them off and say drama is
fucking awesome.
Andrew them less has wonderful taste in music.
Can we just say that on all right,
we've got to wrap this up.
Yeah.
Cause we got to go look at that arrogant brought down.
Um Oh,
before I end,
I got to a just unbelievable sad day in comedy yesterday.
The Great John Pinette uh,
passed away and I got to tell you,
I got to your great jump and that story.
He was just an unbelievable guy.
I only,
I only got to meet him a handful of times,
but he's one of those guys.
You met him the first time.
It's like,
you know,
like Cliche,
like you know,
forever.
First Time I ever saw him I had already,
all he heard was the legend of John Fernet where basically he started doing
comedy and like within six months was headline because he had,
he didn't have the material yet cause you don't even do want to six months.
But his charisma and how hard he was killing it,
he was just such a natural that we're in Boston where it was just such,
we like headlining was so solidified.
Like you,
you,
like we always said,
by the time we came around,
you had to leave Boston to headline Boston because the,
the Boston comedy gods weren't leaving and you weren't going to get funnier than
them.
So you had to go out and get TV credits to just do a headlining set at the
fucking comedy fall.
Uh,
but John Pinette was so funny.
He plowed through all of that in six months.
In the first time I see the guy to hearing the legend of the guy.
Um,
it,
Nick's comedy stop,
uh,
on Kevin Knox,
his show.
And this is after the standup boom ended,
the eighties ended in the early nineties when I started out.
So,
and they didn't learn how to promote a club because they never had to because
people just went to comedy clubs.
So now for the first time ever,
they had to learn how to promote and they was still learning.
So long story short,
it was a Tuesday night at Nick's,
it was maybe 28 people in the crowd.
And John Pinette comes in and just says,
Hey,
can I get up and do some time?
And they put them on and I watched him and he did 12 minutes and he made those
28 people.
It sounded like a fucking jet was landing.
He had them dying laughing and he got us
standing ovation.
Hmm.
Like he had done like a 90 minute blistering set just doing 12 minutes just,
and it was one of those things I had never seen anybody get a standing ovation,
but I knew what the end,
they were going to stand up.
And I remember he just,
he just went on,
he just kinda like sit down,
sit down,
smell going,
like what the fuck was that?
And um,
fortunately I never had to try to follow them.
I did one show with him,
um,
I can't remember where the hell we were.
It was me,
him,
Kathleen Madigan was just a fucking great line up of people.
And like he closed it in Jesus Christ.
He was one of those guys that he would,
and that's that Boston style.
It's like,
I got you and I'm not letting you go and I'm not letting you get up.
And like nobody was the epitome of that more than them.
So going to miss your buddy,
and that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Um,
don't take any shit.
Don't fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Mona.
Lisa.